Speaker 1: All right.
I love this next story.
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham has now
been caught on audio recordings from a little
while ago slamming Trump and saying Joe Biden's
actually good.
Joe Biden is the best person in this post
Trump riot moment that the United States faced
over a year ago.
You have to listen to this stuff to believe
it.
So let's get right into it.
New audiotapes have leaked of Senator Lindsey
Graham saying Trump went too far and plays
the TV game while calling Biden the best person
to have post January six.
Now, these are reasonable comments.
It's yes, Trump has gone too far.
Trump plays the TV game.
Joe Biden was at least a good person to have
in that he brings calm and rationality and
sort of the opposite of the mania of much
of the right.
But the reason it's notable is that Lindsey
Graham is a Republican senator and publicly
he was praising Trump and saying Trump's great
and all these different things with occasional
moments of disagreeing with Donald Trump.
A new audio has leaked of Senator Lindsey
Graham revealing his feelings about Biden
and Trump.
Graham is heard saying he thinks Biden is
the best person to have after the Capitol
riot.
Graham also criticizes Trump in another tape,
saying he plays the TV game and went too far.
So let's get to some of this, some of these
clips, some of this audio.
Take a listen.
Speaker 2: We'll actually come out of this
in moments like this.
Unidentified: Reset the table.
People calm down.
People are.
I don't want.
Speaker 2: To be associated with that.
Speaker 1: So this is from the book.
This Will Not Pass by Jonathan Martin and
Alex Burns.
This is where a lot of these leaked recordings
of Kevin McCarthy criticizing Trump and others
have come from.
And the picture that we're increasingly having
painted for us is of prominent Republicans
who publicly were 98 or 99 or 100% behind
Trump, but privately knew how bad he was and
were actually saying so sometimes.
Let's continue.
Speaker 2: This is a group within our group.
With this.
Speaker 1: Does it give you a rally effect
for a while for a country that says we're
better than this?
Now, what's fascinating about that, before
we get to now, he's going to praise Joe Biden,
Lindsey Graham and Kevin McCarthy and others.
They thought they were expecting in the immediate
aftermath of the Trump riots.
They were expecting that everybody, including
the Republican Trump base, would say this
is too far.
This was wrong.
This was Trumpists.
Trump incited it.
Everybody sees what happened and they would
denounce it.
But then internal polling started to say otherwise.
Internal polling started to say, actually,
people have fought.
Republicans have fallen for Biden stole the
election.
Some of them fell for it was Antifa slash
Black Lives Matter slash the FBI who did the
riots.
They fell for it.
And then we very quickly realized that the
private expectations of people like Lindsey
Graham and Kevin McCarthy, that the country
is not going to stand for this.
We can step away from Trump because everybody's
going to they were wrong and then they had
to backtrack.
Here is Lindsey Graham talking about Biden
being a good person to actually have at this
point in time trying to get the shot right
for everybody here so we can see this.
Okay, here we go.
Speaker 2: I know that, right?
Yeah.
He'll be maybe the best person to have right
now.
How bad can you get it?
Speaker 1: Bill graham says Joe Biden is maybe
the best person to have in the aftermath of
the Trump riots.
Wow.
So if you compare January six, Lindsey Graham
to the Lindsey Graham of today, how stark
are the differences?
Because we should point out that Lindsey Graham
publicly said that he had you.
Speaker 5: Know, he he.
Speaker 1: He hated the way it ended with
him and Trump, but he'd had enough.
Speaker 2: Yeah, you can almost hear.
Speaker 3: In his voice, Anderson, Senator
Graham trying to sort of play out what the
impact of this attack, which as we talked
was was still sort of ongoing as we spoke.
Speaker 1: So there is Lindsey Graham saying
Trump's a pretty good person for this.
Let me see if we can get.
There was one more clip I was hoping to play.
Um.
I guess I don't have it.
Okay, which is fine, but I believe we have
the.
Oh, okay.
I have a transcript of the second tape.
In a second tape, Graham criticizes Trump's
rhetoric prior to the riot he was accused
of inciting, quote, he plays the TV game and
he went too far here.
That rally didn't help talking about primarily
Liz Cheney.
He created a sense of revenge.
So I've said this before and I'm going to
restate it.
I believe that this is worse than being a
true believer, the true believers who really
support Trump, they're at least they're only
wrong and their moral compass is misguided.
And we can make a lot of criticisms of the
true believers of Trump.
The false believers, I believe, are even worse
because on top of all of the bad things that
they are supporting by publicly supporting
Donald Trump, they are knowingly allowing
their country to be damaged for purposes of
political expediency or maintaining access
to the office of the presidency or maintaining
a favorable relationship with their constituents
or whatever the case may be.
I think that the false believers are worse
from a moral standpoint, and we can put Mitch
McConnell in this as well to some degree.
I mean, in the immediate aftermath of the
Trump riots, Mitch McConnell clearly expected
to some degree that the vast majority of the
Republican base would dump Trump.
But Mitch McConnell was part of the Republicans
who also thought the Republican base would
never choose Trump as their nominee back in
2015 and 2016.
So he's been wrong time and time again.
He's been wrong every time about now they're
going to burn.
And so they end up having to kind of backtrack.
And for someone I mean, listen, Mitch McConnell
Graham, they're not political idiots to some
degree.
They're a little bit astute when it comes
to politics.
In some sense, they all seem unable to realize
how monstrously unaffected of a significant
portion of the Trump base is by the things
that actually take place, go all the way back
to grab them by the you know what?
And that tape, it almost seems quaint and
naive in some weird way to think back to when
we thought, wow, Trump's primary candidacy,
it's got to be over, right?
I mean, grab him by the you know what?
You can just do what you want.
And all these allegations, it didn't matter
anymore.
It didn't matter.
And it is a monstrous base.
And if we've learned one thing, it's that
if you overestimate the morality and intelligence
of the Trump base, you end up being wrong.
You end up disappointed or in places you don't
necessarily expect to be.
And that's what happened to Lindsey Graham.
It's what happened to Kevin McCarthy.
It's what happened to Mitch McConnell.
They expected at some point their base would
wake up to the mad that was Trump and they
never did.
And these are their constituents.